president Trump's approval ratings are
nothing special actually they're
extraordinarily loved by historic
standards he's clocking in at 44%
according to the latest NBC news/wall
Street Journal poll his support base is
highly polarized with 85 percent of
Republicans behind him and just 9
percent of Democrats if those rates drop
steadily for the next two years and
given the level of polarization they
certainly could republicans would be in
serious danger of losing the house since
low presidential approval ratings
correlate significantly with House
elections then again Trump support base
may be stable here is why
according to that same poll
approximately 57% of voters say the
Trump is doing about as well as they
expected meanwhile his approval ratings
far outclassed those of Congress which
has just a 29 percent approval rating
that's a nonpartisan statistic and 31
percent approve of Democrats in Congress
while 32 percent approve of Republicans
in Congress the most unpopular figure in
American politics that's still House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi with 19
percent of people feeling positively
about her in any way against 44 percent
who feel negatively about her the
Democratic Party's negatives double-up
the republican party's this relatively
positive feeling toward Republicans
means 60% of respondents are hopeful and
optimistic about the future of the
country only 40 percent are pessimistic
and that's with a sample that shows just
37 percent of respondents who voted for
Trump himself in the presidential
election none of this says that
everybody is comfortable with Trump 52%
say Trump's chaotic style is unique to
this administration and suggests real
problems but the American people largely
agree with from C Genda 86% say a small
group in our nation's capitol has reaped
the rewards of government while the
people have borne the cost
53% say the news media and other elites
are exaggerating the problems with the
Trump administration because they're
uncomfortable and threatened with the
kind of change Trump represents while 37
percent of respondents say they want
Democrats in Congress setting the agenda
19 percent say Republicans in Congress
should do so and 37 percent say Trump
should do so 57 percent of Americans say
Trump is likely to bring change 63
percent of those people say he'll bring
the right kind of change 41 percent of
Americans say the economy will get even
better and 73 percent of those people
attribute that success to Trump only 4%
of Americans think Obamacare works well
the way it is and here is the best
statistic of all for Trump personally 38
percent of Americans say they like him
personally regardless
of whether they like or dislike his
policies all of this suggests that
Americans are giving Trump a chance and
that they're tired of the media failing
to do so they think Trump is gonna bring
change they want to allow him freedom to
pursue that change Democrats and members
of the media who keep saying Trump can't
be trusted with the tiller of government
ought to have an easy solution give
Trump all the leeway he wants he wants
and then watch him pursue policies they
think are unpopular by acting as foils
for Trump the media and the left to
actually prop him up they allow him to
position them as obstacles to making
change
look Trump is in control he's the
president the American people are ready
to see him perform now it's time for him
to step up and create the change he's
preached for so long I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show we're gonna
get to that amazing quasi State of the
Union address in just a second it really
was is the best Trump has ever been and
we're gonna go through it we're gonna
talk about what it meant in terms of
rhetoric what it meant in terms of
policy why it was such a success even
though he was basically preaching a lot
of big government programs where he was
truly successful and why the Democrats
just can't help stepping on their own
bleeps but before we get there we have
to talk about our friends over at
tracker so if you are somebody who loses
stuff all the time right you need to
rush out the door and now you're doing
what I always do you're reaching for
your wallet your keys in your phone and
you realize that you've lost your wallet
or your keys or your phone that's what
tracker is for when you lose your stuff
it makes you feel like a and when
my wife loses her stuff it certainly
makes her feel bad because I make her
feel bad cuz I'm a terrible person but
if you're not a terrible person and you
want to help your wife now I I'm not
help my wife by getting her tracker so
we put the tracker it's this little coin
size device you put it on everything
from your phone to your wallets your
keys and it allows you to immediately
find your wallet or your phone or your
keys so you never have to worry about
losing them again you know we all lose
that stuff so with tracker you never
have to worry about it it's a coin size
device just pair it to your smartphone
you attach it to any anything and you
find its location with the tap of a
button and by the way what happens if
you lose your phone
well you press the button on your
tracker device right and even ask your
Amazon Alexa and your phone rings even
when it's on silent so it rings through
so this is a big thing with my wife she
always loses her phone and then it's on
silent you put the tracker on the phone
and then when you hit the tracker device
it makes the phone app ring through and
that way you can always find your phone
too it's an amazing amazing device we
have a couple of them in our house
tracker calm
is the place to get it and right now if
you go to the tracker comm the tracker
comm and enter promo code Ben you'll get
a free tracker Bravo with any order so
you can have two basically so the
tracker comm promo code Ben to try that
out and has a 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you don't like it you
can always send it back the tracker comm
promo code Ben and it's spelled tra CK
are comm the tracker comm promo code
been spelled just like you see here on
the screen track noe track a.com didn't
use that promo code Ben so they know
that we sent you okay so Donald Trump
gave the speech of his life last night
it was the best speech he's ever given
by far I'm not sure who wrote it but it
was really well-written it was really
good when I first saw the excerpts I
thought that it was horribly written
because it had things about shouting
your dreams and all this kind of
nonsense that sounds like it's women
Joan Baez song but that's not what the
speech actually was the speech had one
moment in particular that everybody is
talking about this morning and they
ought to be talking about it for two
reasons one there was a feeling during
the entirety of the Obama administration
that the Obama administration really
didn't like the military very much that
they thought that the military were
basically a bunch of grunts and rubes
and that they were to be scorned as
opposed to there were people to be to be
honored and Donald Trump didn't do that
last night not only didn't he do that he
did what I thought was it was the best
moment I've seen in any state of the
union address ever actually and that was
when he decided to pay tribute to the
wife of the person who had lost her
husband in Yemen the Navy SEAL right so
this Navy SEAL Ryan Owens he's killed in
this mission in Yemen authorized by
Trump and he brings her wife to the
State of the Union address and here's
what it looked like and you'll see why
it's such a stunning moment Ryan was a
part of a highly successful reign that
generated large amounts of vital
intelligence that will lead to many more
victories in the future against our
enemy
Ryan's legacy is etched into eternity
thank you
[Applause]
okay so posit there for one second so at
the beginning you can see all the
Democrats are standing right there at
the beginning okay now let it go right
the Democrats sit down in sequelae
Harris sitting down the senator from
California
keep going keeps going the applause now
watch what the Democrats are doing
because that's the key to this clip
that's it okay so as this as this as
this clip continued the Democrats
continue to sit here are some
screenshots of what it looked like as
this two-minute elevation continue now
demo some Democrats were saying well you
know we just sat down because the
ovation was up no wasn't right look at
that
stark partisan divide that road down the
center right there that separates the
Republicans from the Democrats even the
Supreme Court justices are standing and
clapping at this point and you can see
in the far right of your screen there's
Nancy Pelosi next to Bernie Sanders
neither of them is standing and neither
of them is clapping for this woman and
that's not the only screen kept like
that here's another screen cap from the
reverse angle you see Al Franken here is
standing and clapping we can also see
again there's Bernie Sanders in the far
left of your screen and Nancy Pelosi
apparently keith Ellison and Debbie
wasserman-schultz were also sitting for
this part so look they're not stupid
enough to sit down at the very beginning
when you're honoring the wife of a
fallen Navy SEAL but immediately as soon
as they can they sit down and once
they're seated they're seated and they
don't get up again and it just
demonstrates oh why why were they so
eager to sit down I mean this is a real
question you know people are treating
this is like this is a silly question
why were they so eager to sit down and
the answer is they didn't want the
optech of the entire chamber applauding
for a long period of time with trump as
presidents in other words they disliked
Trump more than they liked the military
they just liked Trump more than they
like this the wife of this Navy SEAL and
that's what was going on there you know
I got a call this morning from debbie
Wasserman Schultz's office they're very
embarrassed about all of this and and
they wanted to clarify that she was
sitting in clapping and I said okay well
Benny Johnson over at Independent
Journal review he reported that she
wasn't clapping in any case what would
be so bad about standing what would be
so bad about standing in fact George HW
Bush at one point
excuse me Barack Obama rather brought a
brought a wounded warrior setting as to
the 2014 State of the Union address full
standing ovations from both sides of the
aisle but when it's Donald Trump
bringing somebody to the
State of the Union address and it was
really moving I mean you can see she's
weeping for her husband and she's and
she's signaling to heaven I love you
baby as she's looking up to heaven
amazing amazing moment for Trump and the
Democrats make it more amazing because
the Democrats don't know what the hell
they're doing I mean the Democrats are
so hell-bent on trying to make Trump
look bad that they forget that they look
bad and they'll sort of the running
theme of this speech there are a bunch
of themes that Trump hit during this
speech that were I thought very powerful
and very useful and what was just as
amazing is watching the reaction of the
Democrats to all of it so we're gonna go
through it right now so Trump opens by
doing something smart he opens with
there there's been a lot of criticism
that he hasn't paid enough attention to
to black Americans there was a lot of
criticism recently that he hadn't paid
enough attention to a spate of attacks
on Jewish cemeteries Mike Pence tried to
take the the kind of sizzle out of that
by going to a Jewish cemetery in
Missouri and doing some work there but
Trump opens the speech with doubt which
is smart just get it off the way get it
out of the get it off the table and then
he went into his stock speech tonight as
we mark the conclusion of our
celebration of Black History Month we
are reminded of our nation's path toward
civil rights and the work that still
remains to be done recent threats
targeting Jewish community centers and
vandalism of Jewish cemeteries as well
as last week's shooting in Kansas City
remind us that while we may be a nation
divided on policies we are a country
that stands united in condemning hate
and evil in all of its very ugly forms
each American generation passes the
torch of truth liberty and justice in an
unbroken chain all the way down to the
present that torch is now in our hands
and we would use it to light up the
world
he continues along these lines but the
fact is that that Trump is a lot of this
his stock speech but it works because as
you'll see the Democrats don't agree
with the stock speech so the art of
politics the real art of politics is
it's like sumo wrestling basically what
you want to do is you want
bring the audience into the circle with
you and then throw your opponent out you
want to bring the audience into you want
to say I agree with you you agree with
me you know who doesn't agree with us
that guy right and Democrats made a real
easy last night because every time Trump
said something that was eminently true
the Democrats would sit on their hands
or they would fuss or they would moan
and that continued all night long so
Donald Trump you know continues along
these lines I am here tonight to deliver
a message of unity and strength and it
is a message deeply delivered from my
heart a new chapter
[Applause]
of American greatness is now beginning a
new national pride is sweeping across
our nation and a new surge of optimism
is placing impossible dreams firmly
within our grasp what we are witnessing
today is the renewal of the American
spirit our allies will find that America
is once again ready to lead all the
nations of the world friend or foe will
find that America is strong America is
proud and America is free ok so he does
that and then the next thing he does is
he begins describing some of the
problems that we're facing and what he
is here to fix and some of this is true
and some of it isn't but it's again
smart speech writing because he's
creating this this contrast he's saying
here's what it was and here's what I'm
going to fix it here he describes sort
of where we were and then he moves to
here's what the big movement that's
built up around me again all this is
very smart I will not allow the mistakes
of recent decades past to define the
course of our future for too long we've
watched our middle class shrink as we've
exported our jobs and wealth to foreign
countries we financed and built one
global project after another but ignored
the fates of our children in the inner
cities of Chicago Baltimore Detroit and
so many other places throughout our land
we've defended the borders of other
nations while leaving our own voters
wide open for anyone to cross and for
drugs to pour in at a now unprecedented
rate Mart of him to do all of this this
is him just describing all the problems
and he talks about the earth shifting
beneath our feet and the rebellion
starting is quiet protests all of this
is smart it's when he gets to the stuff
where he talks about drug dealers and
criminals that it's clear the Democrats
are not on the same wavelength and Trump
is very good at drawing the contrast
between himself and the so-called enemy
and in this case the enemy is not just
the people on the left the enemy is the
drug dealers and the illegal immigrants
before we go any further I do have to
say thank you to Ari
over at Delta defense so this is a new
advertiser and you guys are definitely
gonna want to hear about them
as you know I'm a strong advocate of the
Second Amendment very strong advocate of
the Second Amendment fact I made my
bones you know in the last five years on
taking Piers Morgan off the air
basically defending the Second Amendment
on CNN and that's why I've teamed up
with the United States concealed-carry
Association to do something really cool
and really important the u.s. CCA
provides industry-leading firearms
education training and self-defense
insurance they make sure also by the way
that if you are in an issue ting
scenario they'll provide you defense if
somebody breaks in your house you have
to shoot them you still may get
prosecuted and they help you out with
that
they are also dedicated to getting more
guns into the hands of more law-abiding
people responsible freedom-loving
Americans who would do anything to
protect the people that they love so
here comes a pretty cool announcement
the u.s. CCA United States concealed
carry Association they're gonna buy ten
of my listeners the gun of their dreams
which is pretty awesome
you're about to get ten chances to win
1,500 bucks for any gun you can possibly
choose any gun you could possibly want
you can pick any gun any brand any
caliber fifteen hundred dollars goes
toward it go to defend my family now
calm to enter defend my family now
dot-com tensor doesn't cost you anything
to enter so you get that entry for a
$1500 gun basically defend my family now
calm right now to enter they are
changing the game for responsible gun
owners as you know I'm a big advocate of
responsible gun ownership and
responsible gun use go over and check it
out right now defend my family now calm
to enter ok so I'm back to Donald Trump
so Donald Trump yeah it continues along
these lines and and there's one point
here where he says that he says
something really smart they're a bunch
of phrases that he uses that are really
really smart one of the phrases that he
uses that's really smart is he says what
would you say to the American family
that loses their jobs their income or a
loved one because America refused to
uphold its laws and defend its borders
that's the sort of smart phraseology
that you need from Donald Trump you need
him to pose his policies in opposition
to Democrats who don't pay attention to
those policies it's smart and the
Democrats react by sitting on their
hands because of course they don't want
people vetted coming into the country
and Trump does again very smart and you
can see I mean we'll go to the parts of
the speech where you can see the
Democrats are just sitting there on
their hands doing nothing it's pretty
amazing
it's pretty amazing there's one point I
don't we can find it because the clips
are kind of cut together now there's one
point where it says when he starts
talking about police and Sheriff's he
says police and Sheriff's are members of
our community and and it's pretty it's
pretty amazing to watch the Democrats
sit on their hands as he talks about how
wonderful the police and the sheriff's
are police and Sheriff's are members of
our community their friends and
neighbors their mothers and fathers sons
and daughters and they leave behind
loved ones every day who worry about
whether or not they'll come home safe
and sound
we must support the incredible men and
women of law enforcement and we must
support the victims of crime I have
ordered the department of homeland
security to create an office to serve
American victims the office is called
voice victims of immigration crime
engagement we are providing a voice to
those who have been ignored by a median
and silenced by special interests ok
what's funny is when he says that final
line and the police line they sat on
their hands too but this is the biggest
one he says free nations are the best
vehicle for expressing the will of the
people and America respects the right of
all nations to chart their own path my
job is not to represent the world my job
is to represent the United States of
America when he says that the obvious
answer is that's true right the
Constitution of the United States makes
you presidents of the United States it
doesn't make you president of Sudan and
President of Somalia president of France
it makes you president of the United
States and amazingly enough I mean truly
amazing the Democrats sit on their hands
for this the applause is muted they have
nothing to say because they don't think
of themselves that way and it exposes
again the vast difference between kind
of right-wing policy and left-wing
policy and right-wing philosophy and
left-wing philosophy and this is not a
conservative liberal divide as much as
it really is a right wing left wing
divide because there is a difference the
right wing left wing divide is that
right wingers actually believe in
nationalism they believe in America now
what we think about America there splits
but we believe in America we believe the
president ought to be upholding the
interests of the people of America the
left wing doesn't believe that a lot of
people on the Left progressives they
believe that they are world citizens
that they're not citizens of the United
States they are citizens of the world I
believe I'm a citizen of
United States a country with a Creed
people on the Left believe that they are
citizens of the world because the entire
world should be united by an
internationalist creed that may or may
not drive with what America wants that's
a huge problem and it's the reason why
Donald Trump has really seen this
upsurge because there still is such a
thing as nationalism you know I've
ripped down the idea of blood and soil
nationalism but I've never said that
nationalism itself is a feeling is the
is the is the thing that's wrong with
the world
in fact what I've said is that is that
nationalism is necessary but not
sufficient if you're a good American you
must be nationalistic but that's not
enough you also have to be
philosophically American so you can say
America is a great country I want to
stand with the flag but you have to know
what the flag stands for there are two
parts to this right nationalism and then
beyond that there's patriotism and you
need both you need both right there they
can't have one without the other or it
doesn't work if you're patriotic for
ideals without being patriotic for the
nation you've written you don't
understand what America is all about
if you're patriotic for the nation
without being patriotic for the ideals
you also don't understand what America
is all about but at least Trump is
providing this nationalistic perspective
and people on the Left are rejecting it
wholesale
they won't cheer for this because they
think that they're global citizens the
world citizens and so you know that you
end up with this bizarre situation where
he's saying he's President of the United
States not of the world and the left is
basically confused by this because they
think the President of the United States
ought to be the head of the UN now we'll
continue by talking about the downside
to two Trump speech and that was the
actual policy discussion we'll get to
that in just a second but see that you
have to go over to daily wired.com you
can check it out their daily wire.com
and and that is $8 a month if you want
an annual subscription then you can get
that at daily wire calm as well right
now you get a free copy of the arroyo
DVD which is a terrific fictional film
set on the southern border about one
ranch or trying to take on the system
that is allowing his land to be used as
a thoroughfare for drug cartels and
illegal immigration it's daily wire.com
check it out over there or go to iTunes
or SoundCloud later to download the rest
of the show you can leave your reviews
at iTunes and so join us we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]